Welcome to Module 02. Here we move from "what is deep learning" to "what is a neural network, mathematically, one neuron at a time."
Three things run this module: the perceptron, the activation function, and the loss function. Those three ingredients — plus backprop — are the entire machinery.
A perceptron is a weighted sum plus a bias, passed through a non-linearity. Written out: y equals sigma of w dot x plus b. That's it. Everything else is stacking and training.
Why the non-linearity matters: without it, stacking layers collapses to a single linear map. No matter how deep you go, you'd still only fit a hyperplane. Non-linearities buy you expressivity.
The universal approximation theorem says a network with one hidden layer and enough neurons can approximate any continuous function on a compact set. But "enough" may be astronomical — depth is what makes this tractable.
Activation choices: sigmoid and tanh saturate and kill gradients in deep nets. ReLU is the default — cheap, non-saturating on the positive side, but it can "die" when a neuron outputs zero forever. Leaky ReLU and GELU are the common fixes.
Softmax sits at the output of multi-class classifiers. It turns arbitrary logits into a probability simplex. Pair it with categorical cross-entropy, not MSE — the gradients are far better behaved.
Loss functions encode what "good" means. MSE for regression. Binary cross-entropy for two-class. Categorical cross-entropy for multi-class. Huber for outlier-robust regression. Your loss is your contract with the optimizer.
Backpropagation is not magic — it's the chain rule applied to a computation graph, cached so you don't redo shared work. Forward pass stores activations. Backward pass multiplies local Jacobians from the loss back to every parameter.
A practical mental model: every trainable tensor has a gradient. SGD updates it by minus learning rate times that gradient. Everything else — Adam, RMSProp, momentum — is a clever way to denoise or rescale that step.
In Keras the Sequential API is a straight stack — input, a few Dense layers, an output. It's the right tool for 80% of classification and regression problems.
The Functional API exposes the computation graph. You build layers as callable objects on tensors, and you can fork, merge, share weights. Use it for residual connections, multi-input or multi-output models, and anything non-linear in topology.
Subclassing Model gives you a custom call method and full imperative control. Reach for it only when Functional cannot express your topology — custom dynamic behavior, autoregressive decoders, meta-learning.
Normalization layers — BatchNorm, LayerNorm — stabilize training by reparameterizing activations. BatchNorm across the batch dimension, LayerNorm across the feature dimension. LayerNorm is the sequence-model default because it doesn't depend on batch size.
Weight initialization matters more than beginners expect. Glorot for tanh-family activations, He for ReLU-family. Bad init can make deep networks refuse to train at all.
The custom training loop. Keras gives you model.fit for the common case, but GradientTape lets you write the forward-loss-backward-update dance yourself. That's the door to GANs, reinforcement learning, and research work.
The three checks before you trust a trained network: training loss decreased, validation loss didn't explode, the predictions pass a sanity baseline. Skip these and you will ship bugs that look like models.
Common first-network bugs: forgetting to normalize inputs, using the wrong loss for the task, mismatched output layer shape, and confusing logits with probabilities when computing cross-entropy.
The labs for this module walk you through each piece. You'll hand-code backprop on a two-layer net before touching Keras. That one exercise pays for the rest of the course.
Next module we move from fully-connected networks to convolutional networks — the architecture that first let deep learning dominate computer vision. See you there.